This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Articles of interest is a show about what we wear. For its first two seasons, it existed nestled warmly within the 99% Invisible Nest. But for season three, host and producer Avery Troubleman has taken it to New Heights as a completely independent production, and I couldn't be more pleased and proud. This is the only episode of Articles of Interest that we will feature, so you have to search for
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯。《Articles of Interest》是一档关于我们穿着的节目。在前两季中，它一直温暖地依偎在 99% Invisible 的怀抱里。但到了第三季，主持人兼制作人艾维·特鲁夫曼将其打造成了一个完全独立的节目，迈向了新的高度，对此我感到由衷的高兴和骄傲。这是我们将播出的唯一一期《Articles of Interest》，所以你必须去你最喜欢的播客应用中搜索
articles of interest in your favorite podcast app and subscribe to get the rest of the story, which is a season-long investigation into a particular look that has come back in style, again and again and again, and Avery is going to find out why. It is a great honor to present to, and Avery is going to find out why. It is a great honor to present to you Avery Trouffleman's Articles of Interest. Oh, my God. Okay. Chapter one. Once upon a time, six years ago, I was given a glimpse of the future, but that future is now the past, so at this point, you've seen it too.
Articles of Interest 并订阅，才能收听节目的其余部分。这是一个历时一季的调查，探讨了一种不断回归、一次又一次卷土重来的特定造型，而艾维将去探究其中的原因。非常荣幸能向大家呈献——而艾维将去探究其中的原因。非常荣幸能向大家呈献艾维·特鲁夫曼的《Articles of Interest》。哦，天哪。好的。第一章。曾几何时，在六年前，我得以窥见未来，但那个未来现在已经成了过去，所以此时此刻，你也看到了。
Oh, my God. So these are jeans for 2018. Oh, my God. for 2018. Oh my god! In 2016 I was allowed to see what blue jeans would look like in 2018 because I was at the office of WGSN, perhaps the world's largest trend forecasting company, almost every major brand and retailer consults them. And they're subscribing and asking to kind of get a projection of what to expect and consume a pan's and changes over the next two years. And it was so exciting that Trend4Caster Sarah Owen
哦，天哪。所以这些是 2018 年的牛仔裤。哦，天哪。2018 年的款式。哦，天哪！在 2016 年，我得以一窥 2018 年的牛仔裤会是什么样子，因为我来到了 WGSN 的办公室。这或许是全球最大的趋势预测公司，几乎所有主流品牌和零售商都会向他们咨询。他们订阅并要求获得关于未来两年消费者期待和消费裤装及变化的预测。这太令人兴奋了，以至于趋势预测师萨拉·欧文
would let me look at WGSN's website to see the genes of the future, because normally WGSN charges thousands of dollars to look at their predictions. What does WGSN stand for? This is why I'm not sure, because I know you went through some rebranding and it's kind of become an acronym
让我查看 WGSN 的网站以了解未来的牛仔裤，因为通常 WGSN 要收取数千美元才让人看他们的预测。WGSN 代表什么？这就是为什么我不确定，因为我知道你们经历了一些品牌重塑，它有点变成了一个缩写，
that doesn't really have a meaning. So that was all from a story I did about WGSN in 2016. And ever since I've been mildly obsessed with this company, it kind of gave me the same feeling as when I was a kid and someone told me what sex was and I was like Is everybody doing this? Is it everywhere?
其实并没有什么具体的含义。所以这些都是我 2016 年关于 WGSN 的报道中的内容。从那以后，我对这家公司就有点着迷了，它给我的感觉就像我小时候，有人告诉我什么是性，然后我就想：每个人都在这样做吗？到处都是吗？
But no one is talking about it In the case of WGSN it turns out like yeah kind of so many companies do use WGSN And as I did more and more stories about clothes and fashion I started asking everyone I spoke to, whether or not they consulted it. Even this director of menswear at a company that makes Hawaiian shirts. You use WGSN? Yeah.
但没有人谈论它。就 WGSN 而言，结果是：嗯，差不多吧，确实有这么多公司在使用 WGSN。随着我做了越来越多关于服装和时尚的报道，我开始问我交谈过的每一个人，问他们是否参考过 WGSN。甚至连一家生产夏威夷衫的公司的男装总监也问过。你们用 WGSN 吗？对啊。
This company makes a low-hashirts. The directive seems pretty clear. We all know what a low-hashirts are supposed to be. But the design department of this company wants reassurance and a second opinion when they're seeing silhouettes shift There's a big shift happening now because it was huge boxy shirts, right? And that was the norm for a long time and it started to get smaller and trimmer fit
这家公司生产夏威夷衫。指令似乎很明确。我们都知道夏威夷衫应该是什么样子的。但这家公司的设计部门在看到服装廓形发生变化时，希望得到确认和第二意见。现在正在发生巨大的变化，因为以前是巨大宽松的衬衫，对吧？很长一段时间这都是常态，然后它开始变得更小、更修身，
So we started to bring our fits in but now it's shifting the other way and becoming boxy and oversized again So sure everything's a cycle. That's a truism But once I learned about WGSN, I couldn't help but wonder the role that forecasters play in the trend cycle. Like if every company is consulting WGSN, is WGSN creating the trends, and then do people buy the trends just because they're there?
所以我们开始收紧版型，但现在它正朝着相反的方向转变，再次变得宽大和oversized。所以当然，一切都是一个循环。这是老生常谈。但一旦我了解了 WGSN，我就不禁想知道预测员在趋势循环中所起的作用。比如，如果每个公司都在咨询 WGSN，是 WGSN 在创造趋势，然后人们购买这些趋势仅仅是因为它们存在吗？
Is the tail lagging the dog? I mean, so many people subscribe to WGSN if you said you know clear plastic studs are gonna be in style in you know 2018 people would probably use them and then we'd let you know how much of it. The chicken all the egg. Yeah that's always a hard one because like I said we do have some of the most influential and recognizable brands in the world using us so if we are giving them that insight and information that they should be doing a certain trend, it's like, did we create it or was it actually about to come to fruition?
是尾巴摇狗吗？我的意思是，这么多人订阅 WGSN，如果你说，你知道的，透明塑料饰钉将在 2018 年流行，人们可能会使用它们，然后我们会让你知道有多少人在用。先有鸡还是先有蛋？是的，这总是很难回答，因为就像我说的，我们确实拥有世界上一些最具影响力和辨识度的品牌在使用我们。所以如果我们给他们这种洞察和信息，告诉他们应该做一个特定的趋势，这就好比，是我们创造了它，还是它本来就即将实现？
So that's a hard one to like directly answer. And you would think that I now in 2022 as a person of the future would know the answer. Like at this point, I could see if WGSN was right about the genes of 2018. And ever since I did that story, I have periodically been asked what I saw if the genes of the future ever came to be. And I have to admit that I absolutely forgot.
所以这是一个很难直接回答的问题。你可能会认为，我现在身处 2022 年，作为一个未来人，我会知道答案。就像在这个时候，我可以看看 WGSN 对 2018 年牛仔裤的预测是否准确。自从我做了那篇报道以来，经常有人问我，我看到的东西——未来的牛仔裤——是否真的出现了。我不得不承认，我完全忘光了。
I don't remember at all because I don't know, a bunch of other stuff came up in the last six years. Oh my God. So these are these are jeans for 2018. Oh my God. So everyone's always like, where they write? What are the jeans of the future? Do you remember? Sarah Oh, and didn't remember the jeans of the future either. I don't remember the visually looked at, but I can definitely find out. Sarah is not a WGSN anymore. She went on to found another company called Soon Future Studies,
我一点也不记得了，因为我不知道，在过去的六年里发生了太多其他事情。哦，天哪。所以这些是……这些是 2018 年的牛仔裤。哦，天哪。所以每个人总是问：他们预测对了吗？未来的牛仔裤是什么样的？你还记得吗？萨拉·欧文也不记得未来的牛仔裤了。我不记得目测看到过什么了，但我绝对可以查出来。萨拉已经不在 WGSN 了。她去创立了另一家名为 Soon Future Studies 的公司，
which takes more of an academic approach to future research. Sarah will write up these long, comprehensive, multipage in-depth analyses about everything. What I'll do and what we'll do on our team when we're looking at trends is we'll always look at it in a context of mega-macro and micro- because that helps you differentiate between what's kind of a fad and what has longer legs and is really going to make
该公司对未来研究采取了更多学术方法。萨拉会就所有事情撰写长篇、全面、多页的深入分析。我要做的是，我们团队在寻找趋势时会做的是，我们总是会把趋势放在宏观（mega）、中观（macro）和微观（micro）的语境下去看，因为这能帮你区分什么是转瞬即逝的风潮，什么拥有更持久的生命力，并且真的会带来
a shift in the world. Trends often get talked about like fads, but trends and fads are different. Trends are longer than fads. Fads are often a look or a product or an idea that gets really popular in a small subset of the population. They hit, and then as quickly as they came, they go away, but a trend has resonance because it hits the zeitgeist. That's what Sarah Owens' true trend forecasting is all about.
世界的变革。人们常常把趋势说得像是一阵风潮，但趋势和风潮是不同的。趋势比风潮更持久。风潮通常是一种在小部分人群中变得非常流行的造型、产品或理念。它们轰动一时，随后又像来时一样迅速消失，但趋势具有共鸣，因为它契合了时代精神。这就是萨拉·欧文真正的趋势预测的全部意义所在。
Connecting micro trends like clothing to larger societal shifts, aka mega trends. The mega framing of the world, which is decades long, to me that's really how you start to kind of talk about trends in their context of the time horizon, though, they'll exist in. So, do you want an actual trend report? Do you want to know what the real mega trends are? Here's your trend report. We are seeing demographic polarization. We are seeing increasing wealth inequality. We are seeing a weakening of global institutions. We're seeing the climate
将服装等微观趋势与更广泛的社会变革（即宏观趋势）联系起来。世界的宏观框架长达几十年，对我来说，这才是真正开始以趋势生存的时间跨度为背景来讨论趋势的方式。那么，你想要一份真正的趋势报告吗？你想知道真正的宏观趋势是什么吗？这是你的趋势报告。我们正在看到人口极化。我们正在看到财富不平等加剧。我们正在看到全球机构的弱化。我们正在看到气候
crisis unfold, and then there's also the mental health crisis. I may be missing a couple, and there's a lot more. Are you worried about that? I think a lot of people could look at your macro trends and be like, yeah, those are all the things that keep me up at night. I think so.
危机的展开，然后还有心理健康危机。我可能漏掉了一两个，还有很多。你为此担心吗？我想很多人看到你的宏观趋势时会觉得：没错，这些都是让我夜不能寐的事情。我想是的。
In the sense that you're saying that the mega trends were so in it that they seem obvious, is that what you mean? Yeah, especially for like, well then, what is this? What is trend prediction? Yeah, I mean, I think Anyone can identify a trend whether it's a mega macro micro what people can't do is Tell the story or see the context of the marriage of those trifecta
在你看来，宏观趋势如此深入其中以至于显得显而易见，你是这个意思吗？是的，尤其是对于……那么，这到底是什么？什么是趋势预测？是的，我的意思是，我认为任何人都可以识别趋势，无论是宏观、中观还是微观，人们做不到的是讲述故事，或者看出这三者完美结合的背景。
coming together. So, yes, you could exist in today's current climate and feel the burden of the climate crisis. You could suffer from anxiety. You can see and spot the mega-trans, but can you understand the connections and the impact, but it's not saying that, oh, weakening global institutions means you're going to be wearing this kind of pattern. It's not that clink cut.
所以，是的，你可以生活在当下的气候中，感受到气候危机的负担。你可能会遭受焦虑。你可以看到并发现宏观趋势，但你能理解其中的联系和影响吗？但这并不是说，哦，全球机构的弱化意味着你将穿这种图案。没那么死板。
You can reverse engineer into those stories. I think a lot of trends are getting reverse engineered right now, or at least some have to be, because there are so many trends right now. Fairy Grunge, ballet core, weird core, the weird of course. Let's talk about the twist that are from the late 2000s. There are simultaneously more trends than ever, and also it seems like trends don't really seem to matter anymore. Clown core also known as Circus core or Clown Prince core.
你可以逆向推导这些故事。我认为现在很多趋势都在被逆向推导，或者至少有些必须如此，因为现在的趋势实在是太多了。仙女垃圾风（Fairy Grunge）、芭蕾核心风（ballet core）、怪核风（weird core）、怪异风。让我们来谈谈来自 2000 年代末的复古风潮。现在同时存在的趋势比以往任何时候都多，而且似乎趋势也变得不再重要了。小丑核心风（Clown core），也被称为马戏团核心风（Circus core）或小丑王子核心风（Clown Prince core）。
We'll swing back to Indie Slee's hipster in the next couple of years. And this attitude towards trends really does feel different from the first time I talked to Sarah back in 2016. There are just too many trends now, or maybe there are just more trend forecasters. Sarah says it's just because there's so much data. Because you see so much pattern recognition and connect the dots and therefore,
我们在未来几年将摆动回到独立摇滚嬉皮风（Indie Sleaze）。这种对趋势的态度确实与我 2016 年第一次和萨拉交谈时感觉不同。现在趋势太多了，或者可能只是趋势预测师更多了。萨拉说这只是因为数据太多了。因为你看到了太多的模式识别并把点连成线，因此，
oh, three's a trend, you know, there you go. And so all of a sudden, you could almost reverse engineer anything to be a trend, just by the default that was so much collateral and data and research out there. Everything is almost a trend in the sense. This influx of trends creates the illusion that almost nothing is out of trend. Like, there are so many styles happening all at once, you can choose whatever you want and everything is sort of up for grabs and okay. And as if to prove that point, Sarah Owen did very kindly
哦，三个点就是个趋势，你知道的，就这样。所以突然之间，几乎任何东西都可以被逆向推导成一种趋势，仅仅因为有这么多的衍生品、数据和研究流传在外。从某种意义上说，一切几乎都是趋势。这种趋势的涌入给人一种错觉，仿佛没有什么东西是过时的。就像有这么多风格同时发生，你可以选择任何你想要的，一切都唾手可得，也都被接受。为了证明这一点，萨拉·欧文非常友善地
end up asking a colleague back at WJSN for the trend report from 2018 and she sent it to me. And sure enough, there were the jeans of the future that had shocked me so much in 2016, they were wide-legged genes with dark-died accents on the sides. And it was so funny. I mean, when I first saw these genes, they did look very new, so much so that I gasped at them.
最终向 WGSN 的一位同事索要了 2018 年的趋势报告，她把它发给了我。果不其然，里面有那些在 2016 年让我大受震撼的未来牛仔裤，它们是两侧带有深色染色拼接的阔腿裤。这太有趣了。我的意思是，当我第一次看到这些牛仔裤时，它们确实看起来非常新颖，以至于我倒吸了一口气。
But looking at them now, I was sort of indifferent to them. Those genes did not look cutting edge, and they did not even look outdated. They didn't really look like indifferent to them. Those jeans did not look cutting edge, and they did not even look outdated. They didn't really look like anything to me. They were just another style of pants. Another trend in the veritable ocean of trends. Everything is a trend. We're constantly being told that this is a trend, that is a trend.
但现在再看它们，我对它们有点无动于衷了。那些牛仔裤看起来并不前卫，甚至看起来也不过时。它们看起来真的不……对它们无动于衷。那些牛仔裤看起来并不前卫，甚至看起来也不过时。它们看起来真的不像是我的任何东西。它们只是另一种款式的裤子。在浩瀚的趋势海洋中的又一个趋势。一切都是趋势。我们不断被告知这是个趋势，那是个趋势。
Rachel Taschen, the fashion news director at Harper's Bazaar, is tired of talking about trends. It's funny. A lot of what is happening now is not forecasting. It's really like saying something is already happening. And a lot of it is because so much of this is manufactured by social media. By its nature, social media encourages trends,
《Harper's Bazaar》的时尚新闻总监瑞秋·塔申（Rachel Tashjian）已经厌倦了谈论趋势。这很有趣。现在发生的很多事情根本不是预测。这真的就像是在说某事已经在发生了。这很大程度上是因为其中很大一部分是由社交媒体制造的。社交媒体的本质就是鼓励趋势，
and encourages many people to act in a similar way. They're all sort of meaningless because there are so many of them. It's like grains of sand or something. I would say probably the only real trend right now is like trendiness itself. So I've been reading a lot of trend forecasting books and a number of them have said that a lot of trends come with counter trends. And that's different from a backlash.
并鼓励许多人以类似的方式行事。它们都有点毫无意义，因为数量太多了。就像沙粒什么的。我想说，现在可能唯一的真正趋势就是“赶时髦”本身。所以我一直在读很多趋势预测的书，其中好几本都说过，很多趋势都伴随着反向趋势（counter trends）。这跟强烈抵制（backlash）不同。
A counter trend just means that two opposing trends can be in at the same time. They're just opposite reactions to the same set of circumstances. So minimalism can be in at the same time as consumerism. 24-7 connectivity can be in at the same time as consumerism. 24-7 connectivity can be in at the same time as the desire to disconnect and go live in the woods. And so, while trendiness itself might be a trend, I think there is a counter trend. A trend that turns away from trends entirely. And there's a look that goes with it.
反向趋势只是意味着两个截然相反的趋势可以同时流行。它们只是对同一组环境的相反反应。所以极简主义可以和消费主义同时存在。24/7 的全天候连接可以与渴望断联并去树林里生活的愿望同时存在。因此，虽然赶时髦本身可能是一种趋势，但我认为存在着一种反向趋势。一种完全背离趋势的趋势。并且有一种与之配套的造型。
Well, it seems like it's a reaction to trends. It seems like people are tired like you are. And they're like, yeah, just these are trendless clothes. Right. I definitely think there's something to it. I think I do have an idea of what we will be wearing in the future. It's a style so obvious that I didn't realize it was a style at all. Americans have been wearing some version of this style since the early days of our nation, and this look has since been exported all around the world. And I think we will continue to wear some version of this look going forward,
嗯，这似乎是对趋势的一种反应。看起来人们和你一样厌倦了。他们会说，好吧，这些就是无风格的服装（trendless clothes）。对的。我绝对认为这其中有些门道。我想我确实对我们未来会穿什么有了一些想法。这是一种如此显而易见的风格，以至于我以前根本没意识到它是一种风格。自我们国家建国初期以来，美国人就一直穿着这种风格的某种版本，而这种造型此后已被出口到世界各地。我想我们未来会继续穿着这种造型的某种版本，
and I think I know why. But I am going to need to use trend forecasting company like WGSN and be like, aha, C trends or a conspiracy. But WGSN is just one company, one of many. And ultimately, as much as designers and manufacturers can follow WGSN's lead and obey their predictions, the clothes still have to be purchased for them to actually make them in trend. They need to find their way into stores and retailers for them to be successful, which means the clothes need to be selected by someone like Peter. I'm an apparel buyer, I'm a man's apparel buyer.
我想我知道原因。但我需要借助像 WGSN 这样的趋势预测公司，然后说：啊哈，看见没，趋势是个阴谋。但 WGSN 只是一家公司，众多公司之一。归根结底，尽管设计师和制造商可以效仿 WGSN 并遵从他们的预测，但衣服仍然必须被购买，它们才能真正成为趋势。它们需要进入商店和零售商才能获得成功，这意味着衣服必须由像皮特这样的人来挑选。我是一名服装买手，我是一名男装买手。
At the time I talked to Peter in the spring of 2022, Peter worked for a very big online fashion retailer. And his job was to determine what this massive online shop would stock and what would actually be available for the consumer to buy. I am pitching my trends for fall 22 right now. And of course, Peter was not judging whatever he would want to stock. He had to think of what the consumer would be likely to purchase.
在 2022 年春天我与皮特交谈时，皮特在一家非常大的在线时尚零售商工作。他的工作是决定这家庞大的在线商店应该进货什么，以及消费者实际上能买到什么。我正在推销我 22 年秋季的趋势。当然，皮特并不是凭空决定他想进货什么的。他必须考虑消费者可能会购买什么。
What is in trend? What is connected to larger, impactful forces in greater society? And so it seemed counterintuitive that in spring of 2022, Peter would show me a book from 1965. It's an English translation of the 1965 book Take Ivy. Take Ivy was an anthropological study of what the students on Ivy League College campuses wore in 1965. This English translation of the book didn't come out until 2010, and I'm pretty sure
什么是潮流？什么与更广阔社会中更大、更有影响力的力量相联系？因此，在 2022 年春天，皮特向我展示一本 1965 年的书，这似乎有悖常理。那是 1965 年出版的图书《Take Ivy》的英文译本。《Take Ivy》是一项人类学研究，研究了 1965 年常春藤盟校校园里的学生穿着什么。这本书的英文版直到 2010 年才出版，我很确定
around that time I encountered it for sale at a J-Crew. Originally, it's published in Japanese for the Japanese market. Take Ivy is mostly pictures of beautiful young white men walking to and from class, lounging in archways, going to sports practice, and you lose track of which college is which, and it all blends into a beautiful mid-century homoerotic American dream. But it's actually quite comprehensive as a culture study. So there are short essays about Ivy League students and culture.
大约在那个时候，我在 J.Crew 看到它在售。最初，它是为日本市场用日语出版的。《Take Ivy》主要是一些照片，拍的是英俊年轻的白人男子走在去上课和放学路上的情景、在拱门下闲逛、去进行体育锻炼，你分不清哪个是哪个学院，这一切都融合成了美国中产阶级中世纪的、带有同性恋情愫的美国梦。但作为一项文化研究，它实际上相当全面。因此，其中有一些关于常春藤盟校学生和文化的短文。
There are these miniature glossaries about different apparel terms terms about the colleges themselves. Like it talks a lot about the architecture of the schools about how large the campuses are, how students need bicycles, that kind of thing to inform the conversation that it's having about dress. And my God, how to explain how these college guys are dressed. Ivy style is kind of difficult to explain. Jason Diamond is a writer and contributor to GQ. I just tell people you start with this book called
还有一些关于不同服装术语、关于学院本身的微型词汇表。比如它谈了很多关于学校建筑的内容，关于校园有多大，学生们如何需要自行车，诸如此类的信息，为它正在进行的关于着装的对话提供背景。天哪，怎么形容这些大学男生穿的衣服呢。常春藤风格有点难以解释。杰森·戴蒙德（Jason Diamond）是《GQ》的作家兼撰稿人。我总是告诉人们，你从一本叫作
Take Ivy. And intake Ivy, they are wearing khakis like loafers and like a pair of modrous shorts, chunky knit sweaters and sweater vests. There's a guy with a blazer and a collard shirt, but it's not like a pair of modrous shorts. Chunky knit sweaters and sweater vests. There's a guy with a blazer and a collard shirt, but it's not like a collard shirt with a suit. It's IV style. It just looks so neat to me. It's kind of a variation on the style more commonly known as preppy,
《Take Ivy》的书开始。在《Take Ivy》里，他们穿着卡其裤、乐福鞋和百慕大短腿裤，粗呢针织毛衣和毛衣背心。有个家伙穿着西装外套和有领衬衫，但这不像是……百慕大短腿裤，粗呢针织毛衣和毛衣背心。有个家伙穿着西装外套和有领衬衫，但这不像是搭配西装的带领衬衫。这是常春藤风格。在我看来，它看起来太整洁了。这是通常被称为“学院风”（preppy）的风格的一种变体，
although some real diehard fashion nerds are definitely gonna get mad at me for calling IV Preppy. Because some people say, oh, well, IV and Preppy are totally different. And I don't really think they are. Why, why not? I just think they're one developed from the other. Describing the difference between IV and Preppy is like parsing the difference between rock and roll and rock.
尽管一些真正的死忠时尚书呆子绝对会因为我把常春藤风格叫作学院风而对我生气的。因为有些人会说，哦，常春藤风格和学院风完全不同。而我真的不觉得它们有何不同。为什么不呢？我只是觉得它们一个是另一个发展而来的。描述常春藤风格和学院风的区别，就像是在剖析摇滚乐（rock and roll）和摇滚（rock）的区别一样。
There is a difference, but it's mostly a matter of chronology. So for now, I'm going to use the terms IV and Preppy interchangeably. It's all about evolution. It's like if you want to like say IV, Preppy, whatever, technically you are talking about going back to that book. You're talking about that one. That's like, again, the Bible for this. So take IV is an amazing document because these guys really look fantastic. And it's not for the clothes themselves. The garments are pretty conservative. It's about how the students are wearing this stuff.
它们是有区别的，但这主要是个年代问题。所以现在，我将把常春藤风格和学院风这两个词交替使用。这一切都关乎演变。就像如果你想说常春藤、学院风什么的，从技术上讲，你就是在谈论回到那本书。你就是在谈论那本书。那简直就是这方面的圣经。所以《Take Ivy》是一份惊人的文献，因为这些家伙看起来确实棒极了。这并不是因为衣服本身。这些服装相当保守。关键在于学生们是如何穿这些东西的。
So you have these guys who come from these like really well to do upper-crust white families, and they're kind of going out of their way to dress down a little bit, but it looks kind of cool. So it's sort of anti-style without even being anti-style. Because these guys are making some choices. You know, rolling up the sleeves, like layering shirts over other shirts, layering shirts over sweaters. Rachel Tashton is all about it. To me, that's what the best part about this clothing is like layering the things and like rolling things up in a strange way. You know, there are such great images of like these guys going to crew practice and they're wearing like sweaters and like shorts and
所以你会发现，这些家伙来自那些非常富裕的上流社会白人家庭，他们有点刻意地打扮得很随意，但看起来又挺酷的。所以这是一种甚至都算不上反风格的反风格。因为这些家伙做了一些选择。你知道的，把袖子卷起来，把衬衫叠穿在其他衬衫外面，把衬衫叠穿在毛衣外面。瑞秋·塔申非常喜欢这个。对我来说，这正是这套服装最棒的部分，比如叠穿各种东西，以一种奇怪的方式把东西卷起来。你知道，有一些非常棒的照片，比如这些家伙去划船队练习，他们穿着毛衣和短裤，
like athletic shorts or they have their pant, they have chinos on, but they're rolling them up because they're getting into the water. Like that sort of style that comes from utility and sort of this kind of self creation, that's what makes it really fun. And that's what the Japanese authors of Take Ivy are so fascinated by. They keep coming back to this one point over and over again. Like, wow, these kids aren't even trying. They're just tossing these things on, and yet they each look so unique and good and different from each other.
比如运动短裤，或者他们穿着斜纹棉布裤，但他们把裤腿卷起来，因为他们要下水。那种源于实用主义和这种自我创造的风格，正是让它变得非常有趣的地方。这也是《Take Ivy》的日本作者们如此着迷的原因。他们一次又一次地回到这个观点上。天哪，这些孩子根本没在努力。他们只是随手把这些东西套在身上，然而每个人看起来都那么独特、好看，而且彼此不同。
That's what the clothing is about. That's why Take Ivy is so popular, because you see people given the same limited palette who are doing these ridiculous things, you know? They're really strange choices made by the people wearing those clothes, especially in that book. That's why I tell people, like, go back to the book, like, go back to take Ivy, because, like, you look at these guys and they're not trying. That's it. That's like, if you're not trying
这就是服装的意义所在。这就是《Take Ivy》如此受欢迎的原因，因为你看到人们在给定相同的有限调色板的情况下，做出了这些荒谬的事情，你知道吗？穿这些衣服的人做出了非常奇怪的选择，尤其是在那本书里。这就是为什么我告诉人们，回去看那本书，回去看《Take Ivy》，因为当你看着这些家伙时，他们根本没有刻意努力。就是这样。这就好，如果你不刻意努力
and you look cool, you're cool. Like, I can't really, I can't fight that. And so, take Ivy is kind of a cult classic, especially for menswear nerds. It's kind of helped define what mid-century style was, and it's become sort of the definitive record, because no American would have thought to photograph and observe all of this.
而你看起来很酷，那你就是酷。我真的无法反驳这一点。所以，《Take Ivy》有点像是一部邪典经典，尤其是对男装书呆子而言。它帮助定义了中世纪的风格是什么，并且它已经成为了一种权威记录，因为没有哪个美国人会想到去拍摄和观察这一切。
Only someone visiting from another country would have bothered to catalog and recognize this look so thoroughly. It was funny to me to read about this writer's experience of men and loafers without socks on and how subversive and rebellious he found that. Peter The Men's Where Buyer says the authors of Take Ivy really nail it on the subtext. They know that this is not a look about dressing appropriately for the occasion of learning. That what these students are really playing with
只有从另一个国家来访的人才会费心去如此彻底地编目和识别这种造型。读到这位作家关于男人光脚穿乐福鞋的经历，以及他发现这种做法具有多么颠覆性和叛逆性，这让我觉得很有趣。男装买手皮特说，《Take Ivy》的作者们确实抓住了潜台词。他们知道，这并不是一种为了适应学习场合而恰当着装的造型。这些学生真正玩弄的
are markers of class. They're like cutting denim into shorts. They're cutting the sleeves off of a sweatshirt. Like they're walking barefoot between classes. And that was such an interesting tension for me between like these markers of obvious wealth, but that the real signposts, at least for these people writing this book, are those things that suggest the opposite, right? Like this kind of uncarriedness. But it's not like you would look at these clothes and be like, hey, everyone looks really
是阶级标志。他们把牛仔裤剪成短裤。他们剪掉运动衫的袖子。他们在课间光脚走路。对我来说，这其中有一种非常有趣的张力，介于显而易见的财富标志之间，但真正的路标（至少对于写这本书的人来说）却是那些暗示相反情况的东西，对吧？比如这种漫不经心。但这并不是说你看这些衣服会觉得：嘿，每个人看起来都真的很
good. The stuff is still in style. Well, this very much is. Peter pointed at a coral colored cardigan. And then he went through, take Ivy methodically and pointed out... Tweeds, tartans. All the other items that were similar to what he was intending to purchase for fall 2022.
不错。这些东西现在依然很流行。没错，确实如此。皮特指着一件珊瑚色的开衫。然后他有条不紊地翻阅着《Take Ivy》，指出了……花呢、格子呢。所有其他与他打算为 2022 年秋季采购的相似的单品。
This kind of loafer. This, I just bought from bleped brand for fall 2022. This kind of loafer. This I just bought from bleeped brand for Fall 2022. No way. Yeah. This is still very much a part of the conversation. Preppy comes back in and out.
这种乐福鞋。这个，我刚从某大牌买了 2022 年秋季款。这种乐福鞋。这个，我刚从某大牌买了 2022 年秋季款。真的吗？对啊。这依然是时尚对话中非常重要的一部分。学院风总是进进出出。
Yeah. You agree that it's a trend right now, the preppy thing? Yes, very much so. Oh my god, so much so. Of course, I asked Sarah Owen for her trend forecaster take. You do see the manifestation of preppy clothing coming through the mainstream for sure. If I had to start to cross-analyze why on the spot. Thanks, Avery. It might be about wanting some control in the world.
是的。你同意现在学院风是个趋势吗？是的，非常是。哦天哪，非常如此。当然，我向萨拉·欧文询问了她作为趋势预测师的看法。你确实会看到学院风服装在主流市场上的体现。如果我必须当场交叉分析原因的话。谢谢你，艾维。这可能是出于想要对世界有一定掌控感。
Very controlled, aesthetic. Like it's very put together and it seems to kind of have this visual cue of being, oh, I've got my shit together. Or it could be because, as Sarah says, looking educated is in and being smart is sexy. We saw that when we thought about the changing face of influences and how we saw influences five, 10 years ago, being very lifestyle and fashion and aesthetic driven,
一种非常受控的美学。就像它非常整洁，似乎带有一种视觉暗示，即“哦，我把一切都搞定了”。或者可能是因为，正如萨拉所说，显得受过教育很流行，聪明很性感。我们在思考影响者的面貌变化时看到了这一点，我们看到 5、10 年前的影响者非常注重生活方式、时尚和美学，
and now it's more about like, who's got a, and who's got opinion, who's an expert, who's that psychologist you follow, who's that engineer you follow and try to, like who's learning things opinion? Who's an expert? Who's that psychologist you follow? Who's that engineer you follow on Twitter? Like, who's learned things like to come? Yeah, like people are hungry for knowledge in a world of fake news and misinformation. But do note that Sarah did not give
而现在它更多关乎：谁有观点，谁是专家，你关注的那个心理学家是谁，你关注的那个工程师是谁，谁在了解事情……谁有观点？谁是专家？你关注的那个心理学家是谁？你在 Twitter 上关注的那个工程师是谁？比如，谁学到了诸如此类的东西？是的，就像人们在一个充斥着假新闻和虚假信息的世界上对知识充满渴望。但请注意，萨拉并没有给出
what I thought would be the most obvious answer, which is that dressing Ivy makes you look rich. It makes you look like you went to private school and you have no debt. It makes you look like you went to private school and you have no debt. It makes you look like you can pop into the lobby of the Yale Club with no eyebrows raised. Like you know how to write a horse. Which, in 2022, makes no sense that it would be entrenched. I just don't think that the social connotations of Ivy are easy to swallow.
我认为最显而易见的答案，那就是穿常春藤风格能让你看起来很有钱。它让你看起来像是上了私立学校而且没有负债。它让你看起来像是上了私立学校而且没有负债。它让你看起来可以昂首阔步地走进耶鲁俱乐部的门厅而不会引人侧目。就像你知道怎么骑马一样。这在 2022 年看来，根本没有理由成为一种潮流。我只是觉得常春藤风格的社会内涵并不容易被大众接受。
Derrick Guy writes for, put this on, and his own website, Die Workwear. People do not necessarily want to dress like these people. So these people being basically like rich white people, like a risk of old money people. So it's hard to sell that image when we're a little bit more politically aware of what are some of the darker sides of that world.
德里克·盖伊（Derrick Guy）为“Put This On”以及他自己的网站“Die Workwear”撰稿。人们不一定想打扮得像这些人。所以这些人基本上就是有钱的白人，类似于老钱阶层。所以，当我们对这个世界的黑暗面有更多政治意识时，很难兜售这种形象。
Right. But if Ivy is indeed back, maybe that means it's no longer the look of rich white people. Maybe the meaning of the look is shifting or has shifted. I think what a lot of fashion is is like convincing people of things through imagery. It's not necessarily making a great product. Rachel Taschen of Harper's Bazaar again. Most designers today are not really, a lot of designers really are stylists, right? They're not necessarily like inventing or creating new clothes. There are very few who actually can do that.
对。但如果常春藤风格确实回归了，也许这意味着它不再是有钱白人的专属造型。也许这种造型的意义正在转变，或者已经转变了。我认为很多时尚其实就是通过意象来说服人们。它不一定是在制造一款伟大的产品。《Harper's Bazaar》的瑞秋·塔申再次说道。如今大多数设计师其实并非如此，很多设计师真的只是造型师，对吧？他们不一定是在发明或创造新衣服。真正能做到这一点的寥寥无几。
And also finding an entirely new way to cover a shoulder. Exactly. Essentially, these days trends are less about, many skirts are in or skinny ties are out. I mean, to some degree, this can be true. But more often, looks are not about individual garments. And they're more about a vibe. Like, I think of outfits, not so much as artistic expression
而且还要找到一种完全覆盖肩膀的新方法。没错。本质上，如今的趋势较少关乎迷你裙流行或窄领带过时。我的某些程度上，这可能是真的。但更常见的是，造型不关乎单件服装。它们更多关乎一种氛围（vibe）。比如，我认为服装与其说是艺术表达，不如说是
but social language. So I think of outfits not so much as artistic expression, but social language. So I think of when people put together an outfit, I think of it as in like writing a sentence. An outfit is a sentence that says, this is what I'm doing today, this is what the weather is, this is who I am. So as menswear writer Derek Guy puts it, a lot of mainstream fashion references, archetypes. The punk, the cowboy, the raver, the blue collar worker. These are frames of references that already exist.
社会语言。所以我认为服装与其说是艺术表达，不如说是社会语言。因此，我认为当人们搭配一套衣服时，我认为这就好比在写一个句子。一套衣服就是一个句子，它在说：这就是我今天的所作所为，这就是天气，这就是我是谁。正如男装作家德里克·盖伊所说，很多主流时尚参考了各种原型。朋克、牛仔、锐舞族、蓝领工人。这些都是已经存在的参考框架。
And you can tell subtly, even if you don't overtly name it, if a jacket is sort of workwear looking or western looking or biker looking. Implicitly, you sort of know if you're dressed up like a business person, or a bohemian, or an intellectual, or whatever, like normcore, coastal grandma, whatever the new archetype might be. It can't be a completely new thing. You can't just introduce a random word and then expect it to catch on. It has to be a way that people can fit into the way they use language.
你可以隐晦地分辨出来，即使你没有公开说出来，一件夹克是工装风格、西部风格还是机车风格。你潜意识里大致知道自己是不是打扮得像个商务人士、波西米亚人、知识分子，或者其他什么风格——比如normcore（无风格核心）、海岸老奶奶风，无论最新的原型可能是什么。它不可能是个全新彻底的东西。你不能只是凭空引入一个随机的词，然后指望它流行起来。它必须是一种能融入人们使用语言方式的方法。
If you were to leave the house wearing, say, a feather boa with a fireman's jacket, it wouldn't send a clear message. It's also why something totally new on a runway looks ridiculous to the point where it almost doesn't register and you're like, whatever, that's weird. Because it's a totally new thing. It's illegible. You know, Nome Chomsky says you can make up
如果你穿着，比方说，羽毛围巾搭配消防员夹克出门，它传达不出清晰的信息。这也是为什么秀场上完全崭新的东西看起来会荒谬到几乎无法引起注意，你会想：随便吧，这太怪了。因为那是个完全崭新的东西。它是无法被解读的。你知道，诺姆·乔姆斯基（Noam Chomsky）说过你可以编造
this random sentence. Nome Chomsky created this sentence that's grammatically correct. But doesn't necessarily mean anything. Colorless green ideas sleep furiously. That's what it's like if you're wearing a fireman's jacket and a feather boa. You can wear a clothes, but sometimes they don't make sense together. Because you have to communicate with people, and I think dress is very much the same way is that people dress in a way to communicate certain messages. together. So this is part of why commercial mainstream fashion tends to stay within the symbols
这个随意的句子。诺姆·乔姆斯基创造了这个语法正确的句子。但它不一定有什么意义。无色的绿梦疯狂地睡觉。如果你穿着消防员夹克和羽毛围巾，就是这种感觉。你可以穿衣服，但有时它们放在一起没有意义。因为你必须与人交流，我认为穿着也是完全一样的，人们穿着某种服装是为了传达特定的信息。放在一起。所以这也是为什么商业主流时尚倾向于停留在符号
and the messages we already know. When clothing is understandable, it references a world and a set of meanings, even if we don't consciously realize it. And so I think for a long time, a lot of us have been dressing in reference to one particular world. I think a lot of us have been dressing like college students. Everybody wears ivy because there's a certain section of Ivy that's just close. Flat front chinos is just close. A Oxford button down is just a dress shirt. It's what people wear. This is why no one calls it Ivy and no one really uses the word preppy. Now these clothes are mostly called classics or basics. So these things have become so popular and so consumed by
以及我们已经熟知的讯息之内。当服装是可以被理解的时候，它就会引用一个世界和一套意义，即使我们没有有意识地意识到这一点。因此我认为很长一段时间以来，我们很多人一直在参照一个特定的世界进行着装。我想我们很多人都穿得像个大学生。每个人都穿常春藤风格，因为常春藤风格的某个特定部分只是普通的衣服。平门襟斜纹棉布裤只是普通的衣服。牛津纺纽扣领衬衫也只是一件正装衬衫。这就是人们穿的。这就是为什么没有人叫它常春藤风格，也没有人真正使用学院风这个词。现在这些衣服大多被称为经典款或基础款。所以这些东西变得如此受欢迎并被
everybody that they are no longer an aesthetic they're just clothing. So it's difficult to say whether or not Ivy's gonna come back because it's here. It's here. It's just cannon. It's just what people wear. It's just clothing. They're just standard. They're not the clothing of a subculture. It is the clothing of the dominant culture. And Ivy has gotten to this place because it has weathered massive mega trends in culture. Like not only has it survived trends,
每个人所消费，以至于它们不再是一种美学，它们只是服装。因此很难说常春藤风格是否会回归，因为它一直都在。它就在这里。它已经是常态了。这就是人们穿的。它只是服装。它们只是标准款。它们不是亚文化的服装。它是主流文化的服装。常春藤风格之所以能达到今天的地位，是因为它经受住了文化中巨大的宏观趋势的考验。它不仅在趋势中生存了下来，
it has survived trends in how trends themselves have operated. But I'll tell you what I mean. After the break. in how trends themselves have operated. But I'll tell you what I mean. After the break. When you think about clothing as a language that needs to be registered and understood, it makes sense that groups of people would all want to use the same words and slang.
它在趋势本身的运作方式的变迁中也存活了下来。但我来告诉你我是什么意思。广告之后。在趋势本身的运作方式的变迁中也存活了下来。但我来告诉你我是什么意思。广告之后。当你把服装看作一种需要被记录和理解的语言时，群体中的每个人都会想要使用相同的词汇和俚语，这就说得通了。
That people would dress in similar ways, and they wouldn't want to just be like, blah, colorless green ideas sleep furiously. And it makes me think that trends are not some sort of conspiracy of magazines and social media and WGSN, that maybe trends are, to a degree, something innate in human culture, a way we know how to follow each other and move within our time. I mean spring blossoms come out and everyone is suddenly aware of new life and the presence of spring and that's associated with different colors and we're all feeling that collectively together because we're living in a world that changes every day and we're all responding
人们会以相似的方式着装，他们不会只想说些诸如“无色的绿梦疯狂地睡觉”之类的话。这让我觉得，趋势并非杂志、社交媒体和 WGSN 的某种阴谋，也许趋势在某种程度上是人类文化中固有的东西，是我们了解如何彼此效仿并在我们所处的时代中前行的某种方式。我的意思是，春暖花开，每个人突然都意识到了新的生命和春天的存在，这与不同的颜色联系在一起，我们所有人都在集体感受到这一点，因为我们生活在一个每天都在改变的世界里，我们都在对
to those changes together. Sophie Tannhauser is the author of Warn, a people's history of clothing. And I think sometimes the corrosive feeling part of trends is that they're so aggressively capitalized on. But I don't think there's anything innately wrong with the way we feel things in unison sometime. I was in Wyoming a few years ago and I went to this bluegrass jam and you could participate and I had a guitar with me and I just came and I was wondering how everybody knew when to do the chord changes and I didn't understand how but being in the circle you could just feel, oh it's time to change. And I think it's sometimes like that with trends.
这些变化做出共同的回应。索菲·坦豪瑟（Sophie Tannhauser）是《穿戴：服装的人民史》（Worn: A People's History of Clothing）的作者。我认为有时趋势那种具有侵蚀感的部分在于它们被如此大肆地商业化利用。但我认为我们有时齐心协力感知事物的这种方式本身并没有什么不对。几年前我在怀俄明州，我去参加了一个蓝草音乐即兴演奏会，你可以参与其中，我带了一把吉他，我只是去了，我在想每个人是怎么知道什么时候该变换和弦的，我不明白怎么做，但身处那个圈子里，你就能感觉到：哦，是时候转换了。我觉得有时趋势也是这样的。
Obviously it can be brutal too. I mean I remember junior high sometimes like that with trends. Obviously, it can be brutal, too. I mean, I remember junior high and the way trends happened. It wasn't fun. It was just survival. Trends can be vicious, and they can be a weapon of mass consumer culture. But as much as I would like to accuse trends of being a byproduct of capitalism, I think trends are larger than that. There were, of course, trends under feudalism.
当然它也可能很残酷。我的意思是，我记得初中时关于趋势的经历。当然，它也可能很残酷。我的意思是，我记得初中以及趋势发生的方式。那一点也不好玩。那纯粹是为了生存。趋势可以是残酷的，它们可以是大众消费文化的武器。但尽管我很想指责趋势是资本主义的副产品，但我认为趋势比那更宏大。当然，封建时期也有趋势。
In the court of Louis XIV, high-end fashion trends were there. They were just very strictly dictated by the monarch. And the deal was, you can't wear silk after such and such a date. You have to switch over from winter fabrics to summer fabrics on this date. No questions asked. Because trends were set by the King, no wondering where they came from, you had to keep up with trends as a show of obedience and patriotism. Louis would change fashions every season as an active way
在路易十四的宫廷里，高端时尚趋势就已经存在了。它们只是由君主非常严格地规定。当时的规矩是，你在某某日期之后不能穿丝绸。你必须在这个日期从冬季面料换成夏季面料。不容置疑。由于趋势是由国王设定的，不用去想它们从何而来，你必须跟上趋势以示服从和爱国主义。路易十四每季都会更换时尚，以此作为一种实际方式
to help the French textile industry. Yeah, so Leon was the center of silk making at that time. And the silk makers in Leon changed patterns every year so that it's obvious if you're wearing last year's silk. But in the transition from feudalism to capitalism, when suddenly there were no more strict overt rules about what to wear and there were no longer permanently affixed stations in the court, suddenly you couldn't tell what class someone was
来帮助法国的纺织业。是的，所以里昂当时是丝绸制造中心。里昂的丝绸制造商每年都会更换图案，这样如果你穿去年的丝绸就会很明显。但在从封建主义向资本主义过渡的过程中，当突然不再有关于穿什么的严格明文规定，宫廷中也不再有永久固定的社会阶层时，突然之间你无法通过一个人的穿着来辨别他们的阶层
by what they wore. Once the noble woman is no longer the only one allowed to wear silk, for instance, if the rich lawyer's wife can also wear silk, then the noble woman has to wear her silk dress in a way that cannot be imitated by the lawyer's wife. So then, of course, the lawyer's wife wants to have that. And so then the aristocratic woman has to move on, and it becomes more and more rapid.
一旦贵族妇女不再是唯一被允许穿丝绸的人，例如，如果富有律师的妻子也可以穿丝绸，那么贵族妇女就必须以一种无法被律师的妻子模仿的方式来穿她的丝绸裙子。于是，当然，律师的妻子也想拥有那个。然后贵族女性就必须继续前进，而这种循环变得越来越快。
And this became sort of the 19th century definition of how trends start and spread. If the elite are wearing something, then you want to dress like the elite. Derek, I again. Just because you want to portray yourself as being of a better status. So that whole trickle-down theory doesn't entirely hold up now, which I'll get into, but it is the most simple manifestation of what trends are at their core, which is a ripple effect of imitation. At their root, trends come from the tension between wanting to stand out and wanting to fit in. trends come from the tension between wanting to stand out and wanting to fit in. Both desires have to be present for trends to disseminate, because if everyone wanted to
这在某种程度上成了19世纪关于潮流如何产生和传播的定义。如果精英们在穿某个东西，那你也会想穿得像精英一样，德里克，我再次觉得，仅仅是因为你想把自己塑造成具有更好地位的人。所以这种所谓的涓滴效应现在已经完全站不住脚了，我一会儿会讲到这一点，但它确实是潮流核心最简单的表现形式，也就是模仿的涟漪效应。从根本上说，潮流源于想要脱颖而出和想要融入群体之间的张力。潮流源于想要脱颖而出和想要融入群体之间的张力。这两种愿望必须同时存在，潮流才能传播开来，因为如果每个人都想
stand out, we'd all be just dressed in our own weird nonsense way, like colorless green ideas sleep furiously, and if we all wanted to dress the same, we'd just wear little uniforms and that would be that. Fashion is both your desire to project yourself as an individual within a group, but also say that you are part of a group to outsiders. So most early 20th century writings about trend dissemination use these ideas of an in-group and an out-group based almost entirely around class and economics. And class is at play in trend dissemination, but it's really not as clear-cut as trickle-down effect anymore. It's no longer the case that you just want to dress like rich people.
脱颖而出，我们都会穿着自己古怪荒谬的衣服，就像无色的绿叶疯狂地睡觉一样；而如果我们都想穿得一模一样，我们就会穿着小制服，那就这样吧。时尚既包含你作为一个群体中的个体来展现自我的渴望，也包含向局外人表明你属于某个群体。因此，20th世纪早期的绝大多数关于潮流传播的著作，都使用了内群体和外群体的概念，这些概念几乎完全围绕着阶级和经济。阶级在潮流传播中确实起着作用，但它已经不像涓滴效应那样清晰明了了。你不再仅仅是想穿得像有钱人一样。
Rich people might want to dress like artists and artists might take inspiration from the working class. Some people might take their fashion sense from the working class that's not even existing today. They might take it from like 1930s or 1940s or whatever. So I think class plays a role but it's not as simple as who owns money. It's more like who has social capital. It's not necessarily financial capital.
有钱人可能想穿得像艺术家一样，而艺术家可能会从工人阶级那里汲取灵感。有些人可能会从甚至已经不存在于当下的工人阶级那里汲取时尚感。他们可能会从1930年代、1940年代或其他什么时期汲取灵感。所以我认为阶级发挥了一定的作用，但它不像谁拥有财富那么简单。它更像是谁拥有社会资本。这不一定是金融资本。
It's clout. Yeah, it's clout. Yeah. Because in the mid-20th century, there was this shift. From wanting to look rich, to wanting to look cool, that nebulous, unknowable, undefinable thing that you really only know when you see it. And that's what the Japanese authors of Take Ivy loved about Ivy. It wasn't because they wanted to look American
这就是影响力。是的，这就是影响力。是的。因为在20th世纪中期，发生了一种转变。从想要看起来富有，到想要看起来很酷——那种朦胧的、未知的、无法定义的东西，只有当你看到它时你才知道。这就是《Take Ivy》的日本作者们喜爱常春藤风格的原因。这并不是因为他们想看起来像美国人
or look rich or look like they went to Harvard. They just thought Ivy clothes were cool. And I guess they are. I guess they are a bit cool. I just didn't recognize them as a look at all. My wife always makes film, and she's like, why do you have so many navy blazers, like the the Brooks Brothers? And like, navy just looks good. You can wear it with pretty much anything. A button-down shirt sort of like looks great on everyone.
或者看起来富有，或者看起来像上过哈佛。他们只是觉得常春藤风格的衣服很酷。我想它们确实很酷。我想它们确实有点酷。我只是根本没把它们当成一种造型来看待。我妻子总是拍电影，她说：‘为什么你有这么多海军蓝西装，就像布鲁克斯兄弟那样？’海军蓝看起来确实不错。你几乎可以把它和任何东西搭配在一起。扣领衬衫看起来对每个人都很棒。
Ivy was also this kind of development of this like middle class uniform that masked class to some degree so that the bosses and the employees dress the same. Part of the experience for preppy women's wear, like it's the act of borrowing from the boys that is still like essential to the style. Martin Luther King, he's kind of got this like preppy look or look at a picture of Alan Ginsburg and he's kind of got this preppy look or Jack Kerrow act. They all have a little bit of preppy look or look at a picture of Alan Ginsburg and he's kind of got this preppy look or Jack Kerrowack. They all have a little bit of preppy in them. There is something sort of rebellious about this and you don't have to be like a member of like the Young Republicans club
常春藤风格也是中产阶级制服的一种发展，它在一定程度上掩盖了阶级，使得老板和员工穿得一样。学院风女装体验的一部分，就是借用男孩们的元素，这至今仍然是该风格的核心。马丁·路德·金，他有一种学院风的造型，或者看看艾伦·金斯堡的照片，他也有某种学院风的造型，或者杰克·凯鲁亚克。他们身上都有点学院风的影子。这种风格带有一种叛逆感，你不需要成为青年共和党俱乐部的成员
to dress this way. It was the uniform of Black Jazz musicians. It was the uniform of people who didn't even go to college. It was just an American look. It was just an American look. And yet, take Ivy is ultimately a vision of America that does not exist anymore. And maybe never did. If you go to Harvard and Princeton and Yale, the majority of students are not dressed like this. So when take Ivy was written, the majority of students were also not dressed like this. When Take Ivy was written, the majority of students were also not dressed like this. Because Take Ivy, that Bible, that reference, that cult classic authority on what this look is, turned out to be not exactly true.
就能这样穿。它是黑人爵士乐音乐家的制服。它是那些甚至没上过大学的人的制服。它只是一种美国风格。它只是一种美国风格。然而，《Take Ivy》最终呈现的是一个已经不复存在的美国愿景。也许它从来就不存在过。如果你去哈佛、普林斯顿和耶鲁，大多数学生并不是这样穿的。所以当《Take Ivy》写成时，大多数学生也并不是这样穿的。当《Take Ivy》写成时，大多数学生也并不是这样穿的。因为《Take Ivy》这本圣经、这本参考书、这本关于这种造型是什么的邪典经典权威，结果发现并非完全真实。
They staged this whole thing for the book. So that world that died long, long time ago. Take Ivy, as you will come to learn in the course of this story, was made as a form of propaganda. For the company that published this book, there were very high stakes to make the Japanese public think that Americans dress this way. Which like, sure, some Americans used to dress this way, but it was once a very small, very elite world, and that style should have died out or disappeared entirely at various points in history. But against all odds, Ivy has been reincarnated over and over again.
他们为这本书策划了整个拍摄。所以那个在很久很久以前消亡的世界，《Take Ivy》正如你在本故事的发展中所了解到的那样，是为了宣传的目的而制作的。对于出版这本书的公司来说，让日本公众认为美国人是这样穿衣的，有着非常高的利害关系。当然，有些美国人过去确实是这样穿的，但这曾经是一个非常小、非常精英的世界，这种风格在历史上的各个节点本应消亡或完全消失。但克服重重困难，常春藤风格一次又一次地转世复活。
For the point where, I think, it will never quite go away. But for now, it's really hard to say what the future holds for that. Like I would have to spend three months kind of analyzing the macro landscape to understand what preppy will look like in two years, where will it resonate and things like that. So I kind of, now I'm like, I think I might be doing that. In fact, I did do that. So this is my trend report. Let's take IV. Articles of Interest is a proud member of Radiotopia from PRX.
以至于我认为它永远不会真正消失。但就目前而言，真的很难说它的未来会怎样。就像我得花三个月时间来分析宏观格局，才能理解两年后的学院风会是什么样，它会在哪里产生共鸣等等。所以我现在觉得，我可能正在做这件事。事实上，我确实做了。所以这就是我的潮流报告。让我们来看看Ivy。《Articles of Interest》是PRX电台网Radiotopia的骄傲成员。
It is written cut and performed by Avery Trouffleman. Kelly Prime edits the scripts and makes them make sense. Ian Coste does mixing mastering in sound design, Jessica Seriano checks all the facts. The logo art is by Helen Shewell sang with photo by Madeline Barnes. The theme songs are by Susami, with a collegiate reinterpretation by the Bielzelbubs, the Tufts University Acapella group. Additional music by me and Ray Royal is work you can find at raydawne.com for R-H-A-E. Special thanks this episode to Zach Fishman and Sai Sian, and gratitude forever to Roman
它由Avery Trouffleman撰写、剪辑并演绎。Kelly Prime编辑剧本并使其合乎逻辑。Ian Coste负责混音、母带制作和声音设计，Jessica Seriano核实所有事实。标志艺术由Helen Shewell创作，照片由Madeline Barnes拍摄。主题曲由Susami创作，由塔夫茨大学阿卡贝拉合唱团Bielzelbubs进行学院风重新演绎。我和Ray Royal创作了其他音乐，你可以在raydawne.com上找到这些作品，拼写是R-H-A-E。本集要特别感谢Zach Fishman和Sai Sian，并永远感谢Roman
Mars. You can and should subscribe to Articles of Interest, wherever you get your podcasts. 99% invisible is Delaney Hall, Kurt Colstad, Vivian Le, Christopher Johnson, Emmett Fitzgerald, Swan Riau, Chris Barupet, Lashemadon, Jason Dillion, Martin Gonzales, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg, Jacob Maldonado Medina, Sophia Klesker, intern Olivia Green, and me Roman Mars. We are part of the Stitcher and Serious XM Podcast family. Now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. And beautiful. Uptown, Oakland, California. Keep up with us at 9i9pi.org.
Mars。你可以在你获取播客的任何地方订阅《Articles of Interest》，并且应该去订阅。《99% invisible》的成员包括Delaney Hall、Kurt Colstad、Vivian Le、Christopher Johnson、Emmett Fitzgerald、Swan Riau、Chris Barupet、Lashemadon、Jason Dillion、Martin Gonzales、Kelly Prime、Joe Rosenberg、Jacob Maldonado Medina、Sophia Klesker、实习生Olivia Green，以及我Roman Mars。我们是Stitcher和Serious XM播客家族的一部分。目前总部设在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市上城区潘多拉大厦以北六个街区。美丽的上奥克兰。请在9i9pi.org上关注我们。
you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。